I'm currently deployed to Iraq as an e6
in the army I have listened to your
podcast and really enjoy your stuff
especially different discipline equals
real I know as a sergeant and as a
leader your focus isn't to be liked
however your soldiers should respect you
respect both you and your rank my
question is how do you tell your
soldiers to do the small stuff tedious
stuff like taking out the trash and
still be light all right well first of
all if we want to get respect from
people we have to give them respect for
sure think about this I think if you
took out the trash sometime you know
thank if you're the you're the boss for
you and see that the trash is getting
overfilled and you just grab it and take
it out just think about what that does
think about what that does the attitude
of the guys if you took out the trash
you you maybe in your mind you think
you'd be losing respect but you actually
wouldn't be at all yeah in fact everyone
looks at you and goes oh he's a good guy
he's taking out the trash it was little
full then he's taken care of it so maybe
if you're insecure you think you'd lose
respect but I think if you're secure in
your ability to lead and if you know
that doing some tedious stuff is gonna
make you guys appreciate you then to me
that means it's kind of worth it yeah
right another example you know we talk
about taking out the trash but like what
if the platoon space has to be cleaned
and on Friday
you you you just say hey guys you guys
can go ahead and roll out I got this mmm
right there's a chance they're like hey
boss we're not leaving yeah yeah no
we'll help you there's course there's a
chance that oh that's awesome thanks
boss and they bail overtime that might
be if they don't respect you at all they
might bail mmm
now in order to regain the respect do
you make them stay in boss them around
more does that increase the respect for
you you see see how interesting it is is
that if you go hey guys that's cool I'll
do it mm-hmm
and you're working hard and you still
got to maintain the discipline and you
don't take any slack but at the U it's
the same balance it's the balance we
talk about all the time so the more that
you treat them with respect more they're
gonna respect you and they're gonna know
that you're not you know too high and
mighty they're gonna know that you're
down to earth when I was a platoon
commander task unit commander I picked
up brass I cleaned the ranges with the
boys that's just the way I operated and
I would recommend that kind of attitude
it didn't make people think Oh chuckles
doesn't have anything better to do they
actually knew I had stuff to do hmm
but what I got to do pick up brass with
the boys yeah build the relationships
set the example they're gonna respect
you for it yeah make sense at the end of
the day do you have something better to
do right because the whole in the big
picture it's like how you say like
that's a leader yeah it's like sometimes
you literally have something no like
sometimes you literally okay the floors
are picking up brass and guess what you
got a meeting with the commanding
officer you gotta go do you you know
sometimes we you you actually do yeah
and what's cool is tactically is and you
heard us saying this at the FTX we're up
in Utah if you see the leader doing
something menial what you should do is
as a followers step up and say hey echo
I got this you can go and lead yeah
that's what that's what you want that's
what I want to do for my leader I want
to take things off my leaders plate as
much as possible yeah now the more you
try and you just have to build those
relationships the way you build those if
you don't have anything better to do
then you get down there and you help you
help clean up the range you helped pick
up the brass yeah that's the way it is
actually did notice that about you and
lathe to um where you know like I'll
have my camera equipment and you know
lights or whatever and it's not a bunch
of stuff but you know you're always like
oh you'll like grab something yeah and
you don't like what I grab okay yeah
don't touch but it wouldn't just mean
you it's kind of like cool cuz we're
just kind of friends or whatever there's
no perceived or know like hierarchy kind
of thing like you're you know but let's
say like at the muster or whatever it's
a bit like you guys have a specific job
I have a specific job you know kind of
thing and meanwhile you and and Lafe
will like if I'm around I'm carrying
something you'll always like grab
something or say hey you need you know
you know at the Utah thing it's like oh
are you good I'm like bro you're the
instructor here kind of thing that's
what I'm thinking in my head and um and
yeah you guys always offered it like
help misty I'm like almost offended like
bro like do I look like I need help
because you shouldn't really be asking
me for active very capable individual
yeah and the small tedious stuff the
other thing is you explain to him why
it's important right about to answer we
give a whole time why is it important
why is important that the platoon Hut's
clean well cuz I want you guys to have
time off over the weekends and not be
stuck here cleaning because the
commanding officer came in and saw that
this place look like a hellhole okay
well that makes sense to us we
understand why you want us to clean now
you you want us to clean so that we can
you have time off you want us to clean
so you want us to train hard you want us
to do this because cuz we want to be
ready for combat because I want you guys
to be able to come home to your families
make sure they understand why they're
doing what they're doing and if there's
no reason why do if the reason I mean
even cleaning even taking out the trash
there's a reason for that right there's
an actual reason for that we can't just
have junk everywhere so explain why
participate when you can build the
relationships with your troops you'll be
good